what's going on man my kids how are you
look at me are you kid
thank you you're the real shocker here
did you see dinero last night at the
pitoni zone he's no I'm straight so I
didn't watch at Tony's but I did see the
highlights let's watch this clip this is
a good one I'm gonna say one thing [ __ ]
Trump arms
really took a risk playing to this
audience that's what I was but then
again look look at the mirror look like
an old man with his fist pumping yeah 74
[ __ ] you know whatever bob says I'm okay
with get off my lawn Trump
oh you got a standing ovation I can't
believe it yeah I can't believe it
that's unheard of tough crowd ya hear
that
I'll say this he's consistent absolutely
he says the guy said he's gonna punch
Trump in the face of you ever seen
that's not wavered he said if he was in
a restaurant and Trump walked in he
would leave I like that then he bar him
from all the no booze - yeah I don't
think Trump ever went to a Nobu in this
one no Beauty a little oppressed for the
restaurant smart can't come to Nobu and
there's just a picture Donald Trump
smiling in KFC on his plane like yeah
it's good a happy meal and by the way
the guy telling me that Cory Cory I know
that the iPhone has the faces album [ __ ]
of faces album I want to name my [ __ ]
phone Cory explain you can't name it
when you load it to the new software a
couple years ago Apple you keep all the
things you've named your photos and
iPhoto is now gone president piece of
[ __ ] I just did the update to let me see
this Jim is very upset because in iPhoto
you know he named all of his photo I put
on your laptop right who does that so
like if he had a celebrity
everyone to look up his photo with
Russell Peters he could just type in
Russell Peters cuz he named it that all
right and he could find it sure but then
they updated iPhoto to photos just
straight photos and now there's
subfolders who they took them off
there's no reason for them to have done
that it's just a scumbag they do [ __ ]
weird things like when you um buy a
movie yeah we downloaded it would go to
your iPad right now you buy the movie
and it tells you it's there and then yes
if you want to download it no I just
[ __ ] yeah I [ __ ] down wanna buy it I
bought it I want to [ __ ] put it on my
iPad well now they would they want you
to watch in the class they want you to
use this I know but when you're on a
plane it doesn't help desk clouds right
right
it doesn't help you I really started to
hate them because of what they're trying
to manipulate you into
doing in the way they're trying to
manipulate people into interacting
Episode II yeah and you know I'm friends
with this guy named Denzil fee gelsen
he's the guy who created iTunes really
yeah and I spent a week with him in
Chile last year and and we were talking
about it cuz I don't know why they
[ __ ] up my could perfectly good idea
he said they took some that work and
[ __ ] it up yeah they've done some
really complicated for no reason it does
it does get fresh drinks they have a ton
of those a ton of movies from iTunes and
you'll get on the plane like oh you know
I'd love to watch well too bad cuz you
got it even down you didn't spend a half
an hour downloading it before you got on
the plane yeah and now when I like some
of my [ __ ] when I'm not on Wi-Fi will
show up on my iPad and then when I'm on
Wi-Fi it disappears I'm where'd it go
right hi the system stinks
I mean you're on tour Russell Russell
can we mention before we you came in
that your openers like guys who work
with you I would I mean I'm too dirty
dope of you but guys who open for you
like a Greg guy real go rogue L talks
about [ __ ] what how awesome these
gigs are and he flies great
accommodations Jim Jim said that he
would like to open for you I would put
your much fortune for the amenities the
amenities I don't know if Russell's
crowd would like me to be honest I'm
probably not right for that wouldn't but
I mean that's a good point maybe do bi
do bi bi bi career they would not be a
probably they would not what would they
like in my acting device all the sexual
[ __ ] yeah you know it's funny as my new
Act has some sex stuff and people like
are you sure you want to do that act and
do my boom just the act I'm doing now I
mean that's the way it goes yeah so you
don't you don't cater specifically
towards anything well I try not to cuz
it's just what's the point of being you
yeah yes I don't see you yeah
have you got have you gotten to spots
where you're like oh god like because
you you only you do these big venues do
you get your other other other countries
where you're like oh god this this
doesn't work as well and let's not on
this tour I mean there's some things
that the audience is in his mixed as I
wanted to be some jokes may fall a
little flatter than they should have
yeah that's just the way it goes you
don't care I don't care I mean I care
obviously but this is the act I'm doing
right now so you know this is I can't
change it for you I can but not going to
it's it's a bit pander II and it's
seems [ __ ] not true to yourself but is
it weird that like when you have people
in your we've all had celebrities in the
audience but you get guys like from the
Saudi royal family like like really high
pressure guys and we're in their country
it's out there here that's [ __ ] at the
Comedy Cellar like they're in Saudi
Arabia water on you and they run the
country well those guys get it the most
they understand everything the best
because they've traveled the world
they've studied abroad you know they
have to keep up their appearance for
whatever their appearance is up for but
they really enjoy the show because to
them it's like a break from everybody
just kissing their ass all day you know
they like it yeah and I don't talk to
them when I'm on stage cuz you're not
allowed to talk to them right and nor do
you want to take that chance of talking
to them and saying the wrong [ __ ]
thing right and it's not even them that
will get upset so one of they're like
you know one of their followers that
gets upset on their behalf and wants to
kill you for their honor so I don't I
don't want to find out what the wrong
side of this train right so you don't do
that yeah I don't you don't
acknowledgment all the audience uh no
they'll tell me sometimes we're like
so-and-so's here they're sitting to that
that's I don't don't talk to them who
made you nervous when they were there I
get nervous around other comics I think
it's what my problem is
thank you know any of them what you guys
feel like they're [ __ ] judging me you
know yeah I mean no comedian likes to
know that a comedian is therefore first
of all when a comic is there for your
headline set you're like they're going
to be gone by the end of it had some
friend show up the other day and I was
like oh are you still here yeah they're
gonna watch and see one hacky thing and
they're gonna leave my shot yeah yeah I
hate this but wait who was that they
said in the audience don't talk to him
oh it happens all the time they're like
a member of the royal families here one
of the princes one of the princesses
whatever it'll be whatever country when
there's so many you forget like when
you're here you forget that there's
actual royal families all over the world
yeah right yeah and it's so bizarre cuz
you're like really that's a thing still
why just gonna say when you were like
yeah it'll be one of his followers that
comes and gets you it's like
mind-blowing that there are countries
where the people feel so passionate and
good about their leaders well you know
it's a weird world we're living in where
people feel passionate and good about so
many other weird things too right yeah
yeah whose opening for you
Johanssen oh my god yeah Jake is really
good yeah Jake's Jake's a beast you know
I was such a fan of his growing up as
well I used to record him when he was on
Letterman and and then when I heard that
he would work with me I was a great [ __ ]
me and he's clean and he's hilarious
yeah I was really funny and completely
TV clean no he get dirty I've got it
dirty but he likes funny when he does
swear I'm like so weird I've never heard
you swear before you know so when he
held you like 20 minutes in front of you
in 20 off the top and and he'll know
what to do and like in again Saudi
Arabia he's fine he's the least of my
worries oh really yeah I'm more worried
about me with a so you've performed
force in Saudi Arabia I have yeah cuz
that's gotta be like insane yeah you
don't you don't you don't just at all
even when you're in Saudi Arabia I mean
they tell you know like the promoter aka
one of the royal family rehearse will
pull me so they're like they won't send
you their cronies they'll so they'll
come to you direct because they're cool
like okay yeah you direct other people
like I said they're from yeah they'll
send like some [ __ ] flunky for
somebody else but the prince will
actually come and talk to me directly
like hey I'm so happy you're here thank
you
listen do me a favor don't mention
religion don't mention the world family
and I go I was gonna do that anyway goes
I try not to do too much sex I go huh I
look at I'm gonna go
we all have sex man yeah Wow
I go we all have sex and I go you know
we don't all have we're all families and
we don't all believe in God so how about
I'll do the sex stuff but I won't be as
graphic as I could have many goes thank
you that's all I ask
and it's not like it's not like you will
do this yeah very very like any other
game they just yeah very apologetic
about it because they like listen I
don't have a problem with it but these
[ __ ] people will well and how do the
people react to it like is there a
Duggar dude in Saudi Arabia when I got
onstage I was I basically greg was on
that show wasn't he I'm sure he was
Craig was on the I took Greg Greg will
go one of the Julie is stunning to Saudi
Arabia to perform any [ __ ] kill of
course he did he get Rogal is [ __ ]
hilarious man yeah hils yeah he
destroyed and then you know we're
performing and I'm standing in the
middle so I'm standing on stage in the
middle because that's where the aisle is
because they're the men on the right
and women on the left you couldn't they
wouldn't make sure yeah yeah so I stood
right at the aisle and perform to the
aisle women I would just turn my body
and about them in I turn my boy faked
yeah is it awkward though it was for
maybe like the first couple minutes then
you get used to it it turns into what it
is you do an hour in that session that's
so and a half wow they're trying to
modernize things a lot right very much
it's doing some guys doing some big
changes over there there really is funny
cuz they you hear about it cuz WEA just
did a big show over there too and it's
actually this huge over there over there
in India as well yeah yeah it's like
ridiculously huge my uncle who lives in
Calcutta who lives in like a little
village like uh he knows villages you
see on like UNICEF commercial yeah where
it's all [ __ ] mud and flies yeah he
lives in one of those I don't know I
asked him if I could buy him a condo
he's like no I like it here I'm like
this is weird so I go to his place and
it's like you know one of these just
just cement wall places he lives in
let's just like they put cement down and
they don't put like a floor really but
like cement wall just walked in roof
do they know you there any I'm sure they
do you're Steve like not in those little
villages now they just know that I'm not
from there when they see me so I go to
my uncle's place and he's got like
posters of [ __ ] Stone Cold Steve
Austin on the wall and who's the guy
doing acting now the rock no the other
one John Cena yeah John Cena John Cena
on the wall yeah it's amazing
like not like like frame pose like just
those little like a [ __ ] teenager not
good boy they got him that's your mom is
that is a Ryan O'Neal Ryan O'Neal yeah
so who over there are the people that
are trying to maintain tradition in
Saudi Arabia because it seems like
obviously the guys are the prince who's
in charge now he's trying to modernize
things and it feels like a lot of the
people when they get a taste of it like
it oh yeah I mean they don't rebel
against they're not the people so much
there's like these things
there's these people have they're called
the cultural police or the religious
police mm-hmm and then literally like I
was in the mall and the guy some random
guy just walks up to me and like did you
pray today I'm like what what did I know
what would you say to them and then
somebody with me because you can't be
rude to these guys apparently so they
had like somebody with me who spoke
Arabic they were like oh and he was just
like looking at me like [ __ ] how dare
you Wow
he said oh no he's not from here he
doesn't what if I if I was there he
would look at me and no I'm not I don't
it would still ask you really yep there
were they don't because there's people
it look like there's Arabs that look
like you got it especially you say did
you pray today everybody ask you an Arab
I'm like huh and I know what he's asking
because the guy warned me before I got
to the mall if these guys come up to
y'all you know but it's it's so weird
you can't be rude to them no and I could
part of me once when we [ __ ] you yeah
right yeah okay ever hey you're wrong
response yeah completely watch eat love
pray yeah no but I've been meaning to
yes yes you go that's amazing I was
praying that I would weird the PC Polly
like people say all the PC police over
there it's actual police actually
they're coming up on you and you guys
Wow
well how are the malls over there they
have every [ __ ] dis it's all designer
stores and they're never open Thanks
because they gotta pray five times a day
so every time I would go to the mall it
was like a [ __ ] prayer our a prayer
time and I was like is this small ever
I'm went there four times it was never
over cuz this [ __ ] ever open
they shut down the whole mall yeah it
shut it down yeah of course it's Gucci
Louie her maze it's every designer
everything designer there's nothing
cheap in those moles Wow yes it's like
oh no a mall here but probably costs a
lot more there yeah but over here X is
there oh really
yeah they got a lot of money over there
know if you're worth it what are you
doing did you go to Dubai do you spend a
couple days there I've spent many time
at much time there I've been going there
for 20 years now okay I really want to
go wants to go to the top of the [ __ ]
tower I think you know I've been there
as many times I have I've never gone to
the top of the tower you don't want to
it's never occurred to me because I have
an idiot
I know staying that hotel in there no I
stay in like like the first time I went
to Dubai
none of that [ __ ] existed so we went
was there it was the Hyatt was the only
hotel there and was in the middle
[ __ ] desert and we would perform at
this place called the the what was it
called it was like the safe or something
like that it was like this the vault it
was called the vault okay and it was
this nightclub in the basement of the
Hyatt and then as soon as the show was
done it would just fill up with hookers
like Russian hooker Wow take my room but
these were women and and I didn't
realize they were hookers and I thought
like I was I thought these women saw me
on the show and I killed or something
yeah because they were all like talking
to me I'm like friendly and I'm like
alright how expensive are they there
it's gotta be crazy well it's the thing
at the time I didn't know I didn't have
money first of all for frivolous vaginas
but the promoter bought me one and I was
so scared of aids in like 98 99 sure and
that cuz we didn't really know much
especially back then even that I just
took her up to the room and jerked off
on her that's all I did that's fine I
was like you know what faith yeah happy
to I gotta have to do anything he's
gonna jerk off yeah so you know that's
what happened then but that's why you
haven't been up to the top of the tower
that you there's a new Mall of Emirates
so there's this new hotel there's this
new moat this and then by the time you
get there that the that tower ends up at
the back of the [ __ ] list what's like
a what's the hotel that's amazing to
stay in there I said dying to go to
Dubai you really want to go yeah I've
been saying that food here goes a lot he
does he sure does DJ it goes everywhere
yes my but never makes sense cuz I'm
friends of the guy and I know he doesn't
know how to DJ
that he's terribly terribly you know she
doing his show and I'm gonna remind him
that he's horrible to me when he started
DJing you know 50 cent asked him to
DJing he hadn't done it before yeah and
this is for your a guy who's like a DJ
got like he like vinyl DJ yeah this will
drive you insane he took you know the
360 machines with the buttons on him
yeah the sound effect machines he got
two of them and he just put a bunch of
songs on him and actually programmed one
of the buttons to do a record scratch
sound effect yeah oh yeah no he would
just sit there pushing her his mix tapes
back in the day yeah and I was like what
is this a bear bear
well kiss and then the song would start
you're like what is that good because
yeah and then and it was always the same
cut right cuz houki wouldn't is the DJ
was terrible and so his mixtapes weren't
on the skill of DJing but what he would
do is he would steal songs from studios
so artists would have unreleased songs
because the tape was stolen
who kid would steal the tape and then
release yeah that was the whole purpose
of buying the who kid mixtape writing
today because he had 50-cent stuff
before anybody had 50-cent stuff right
he's basically the guy that broke $0.50
that's right that's right but it was all
unfinished stuff yeah it was like all
these demos right and I remember like
buying one of his mixtapes and it had
like this this one version of a of a
biggie song that had Keith Murray on it
that never came out was a cool [ __ ] you
get that yeah it's just I don't know
yeah that's no no it's the [ __ ] gave
it to be just give him [ __ ] [ __ ] with
him he really does first he does so
what's the best motel him to buy I don't
know there's a seven star hotel in Dubai
but I've never stayed there no I'm I
have to end up footing the bill oh yeah
and then I am no problem is when I'm on
the road and I gots a say all of us were
on the road I'm not gonna go stay in a
different hotel than you that's cool so
I'm not went when Jim and I got
literally the last time Jim and I were
on the road too not the last time when
we went to Montreal though yeah Jim
stayed in a different hotel he was at
the W you were at the well at the I had
to hire I say at the inner Canal because
I hate the W the Hyatts [ __ ] I literally
would sleep on the [ __ ] outside under
the stage before I stay there but the
other ones itch me I can only stay in
certain hotels where I can't sleep I
like the bathrooms in the doubler too
[ __ ] yeah I like my [ __ ] useful I
don't dump through opaque glass you see
your silhouette [ __ ] just sitting
there with a newspaper
yeah like the newspaper was here it
really was a little guy big papers you
did get us into a nicer hotel in LA then
I would have gotten into without you
though which ones I have to give him
credit for that
Motel H yeah we said the London which is
great yeah no other London's nice so
what is the hotel in Dubai that Jim has
to see I'm
yeah I understand the one who's
virtually so you gotta stares at the
Burj Khalifa I think it is no no that's
the Calvin Klein hotel the seven star is
that the sailboat one I don't know what
are you seven star hotel
it is two sailboat one yeah yeah what's
the sailboat Hotel in Dubai what makes
it what makes it a seven star hotel how
nice can you make it there it is it
looks like the the building is shaped
like say golf at the top of the building
oh my god that's one where they had
Tiger Woods golfing at the top of the
building one time they had somebody
running around the building I think
David Beckham jogging around the
building like that's pretty fantastic I
mean it does look like a very nice bath
to stay there one day but you know I
think I would have to be on my own and
then it's gonna cost you a fortune
how many Knight is there probably over
150 bucks easily they might have a
Groupon we're saying the [ __ ] I want
to get a girl to go over there with her
while you do this Jim why I'm gonna be
out there I think with January I'm gonna
be out there in January shooting Lane
I'm a shooting my new special in Abu
Dhabi how's Abu Dhabi air here that's
pretty nice that's pretty cool too how
do you decide like where you're gonna I
just did I told my brother uh [ __ ]
really early right yeah I think maybe
before we got on to where I was like I
think I want to shoot my next question
on Dubai and he goes okay and then we
came back goes how about Abu Dhabi I go
sure what's the difference they're both
nice they're both nice Dubai's the Abu
Dhabi and Dubai are always competing
with each other they're the same royal
family oh but different brothers or
something so there I see so there it's
like you know they're always trying to
one-up each other hence why you know
Emirates Airline is amazing and then
Etihad which is the one out of Abu Dhabi
came up with these Suites the private
suites where you have a bedroom a living
room in a shower so that's why
everything is amazing because they're
competing yeah yeah yeah and they're
stinking rich so they can do whatever
they want so we all benefit from that
we're all anybody well they also benefit
I mean 40 grand a flight is all my
private suite sending something like
that right 30 35 maybe thank you maybe
they could send me an a young lady
friend and I'll give them a review yeah
let them know you look great you're
getting [ __ ] on that point council
review this was bad see if you can make
a deal pearl please killer Norton see if
you can make a deal for social posts
what about like
three Instagram posts in a Twitter
mention I'm open to all yes it's not
that bad a night oh that's oh that's
a--that's a UH oh it's only 1600 1600
bucks a night that's not bad at all
no brother why aren't we staying there
although panoramic the panoramic
one-bedroom suite is 17 yeah there's
there's 11 of us when we're on tour I'm
not looking to by the way that's a lot
of money that's the cheapest room it's a
lot of money I'm just saying that 9
grand a month
9 grand and nine thousand dollars a
night look at that bed Royal two bedroom
suite two bedrooms that could save you
okay so you can split it in between a
cup of water boy I'm gonna have a
[ __ ] I'm having a council meeting is
are nice yeah
now are you Russell would you could you
if the meeting in Singapore goes well
are you watching this between between
Trump and stump yes right would you then
go like okay maybe we're opening up
North Korea a little bit maybe it's time
Russell Peters there's a show in North
Korea would you be the first comedian to
do now area if if there was to be I
would like to be that guy yeah but I
think it might be Kenji young or
something hey Jim Norton say hi but you
would do it for sure right oh yeah yeah
I mean first I gotta do South Korea I
think yeah oh you've never done done
South Korea I just did Japan for the
first how is that amazing it was
ridiculous I got a standing ovation when
I walked out really yeah and I we didn't
expect it they the they had to keep
moving the venue to a bigger venue I
mean if we'd only ended up like 1,500 to
2,000 seats but I mean again Japan
nobody thinks Japan you're gonna go
there right your musicians go there and
kill it all the time but right you know
comedy it's something you have to really
understand it much more yeah I have to
understand the nuances yeah what makes
it funny sure where's the biggest place
you're doing on this tour so far what
have we done we did we did Wembley Arena
in London it was 13 or 14 thousand and
then we did Sydney Australia again that
same venue I'd I've so I think we sold
about five or six times now the Opera
House
no eyebrows is tiny is that the only
event oh yeah but now no eyebrows it's
just full of small rooms no that was one
venue in the Opera House I didn't take
3,000 people was that I was just it was
it was a room with a bunch of comedians
I mean I did that about 10 or 11 years
ago that that Opera House yeah I didn't
even sell it I just literally did it
with him he does bigger rooms my Netflix
special rece huge huge we did that
whatever was called that they change the
name every time it's arena go back when
it was about 13,000 people there too
it's pretty nice not too shabby not too
shabby
yeah I would go and watch Russell do it
i-i've seen Russell came to my HBO in
the first hand of fresh Bo which was
2006 we're promoting lucky Louie and I
did a half-hour as myself and Kevin
Brennan that night it was I think the
first time Russell I met Yoshi brought
Russell yeah and he was such a good guy
he because you know we're both big kiss
fans and you brought me a nice kiss book
which I did not have like a photo but
was beautiful yeah I said what a sweet
guy this is just to bring me a nice
welcome gift for my half hours tablet it
was good yeah I look back on that I was
a fat [ __ ] pig but I mean I look back
on mine now and watch myself get fatter
throughout this guy how bad do you want
a photo at the original four-member it's
all I think of how I [ __ ] took a gig
a really good money gig for me when they
did the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame
induction cuz I didn't know if I get the
picture I will regret that for the rest
of my you didn't do it I didn't go get
the picture oh you took a gig know that
I didn't know if I would get the picture
if I didn't know if it would happen
gene Simmons said it probably wouldn't
have right no I said no I didn't know a
backstage with them I didn't know if I'd
get it and I said to gene what I've got
in that picture with the four of you and
he goes of course we all know you all
will always say [ __ ] like Ted to you
nobody sees you kind of honest though I
think he would have said no and they all
do know me I would all of them would
have known my finalists I haven't met a
sore Peter yet oh my god I really got I
think we should get on top of Peter
first cuz he's in his 70s now I would
love to yeah I'm sure Peters uh
Peters wife is very proactive in his
Lydia Korea no next wife I forget his
wife's name now she's
I saw I replacing I don't kiss geeks I
know ex-wife's name yes well technically
no his third wife from yeah yeah wife
was the copper tone model chest right
yeah I vanished I did some hard rock I
was at some hard rock thing and Peter
and I were there together well I was
playing and Peter came out and did a
couple of that's pretty cool it was
[ __ ] great well why don't you tell me
about these than what you call me great
I didn't know about till they were there
okay I didn't know about it until they
actually brought Florentines again their
call before me kissing Wendy how much
kiss feeds I follow on my Instagram
really yeah that's amazing
I got a nice picture with them tonight I
feel that I think that's Peter and Jase
yeah that's good when did you start like
so when you're growing up is it all
hip-hop and kiss well no I mean you got
a see I got my first kiss album in 77
okay I was still six on my way to seven
it was love gun now and then that just
changed everything for me you know I
think destroyer was mine yeah there's a
run right before yeah well it wasn't
rock and roll over in between that yeah
destroyer rock and roll over and then
love done yeah so did you become a
hip-hop geek uh some in the early
eighties I like my brother wasn't a funk
and stuff so but at that time there was
rap songs coming up but this still
didn't have the name hip hop yet so we
just thought it was like yeah we still
thought it was fun because we were IMing
over the funk songs and then we didn't
know was rapping and then we just like
oh it's like some thing they're doing
over this and it sounds kind of cool and
then you know and then tada and when did
you kind of go like now I'm gonna stick
with my guys well lick it up after look
it up and they took the makeup off and
analyzed camera after I was like now I'm
done yeah and then stuck with them to
the no maker no you you look it up and I
liked it and they animal eyes when they
changed Bruce they had Bruce Kulick and
in the group and I was like okay it's
taken too many changes now yeah and I
don't like the look of this anymore and
then the glam rock [ __ ] was starting
they all the 80s yeah and I was like
NASA not for me but you know they did
the same thing Ozzie did to a certain
degree you were just a little bit and
those bands that survived that that
stuff and didn't just get wiped off the
map
made minor adjustments so that people
who liked them before were like what the
[ __ ] are you doing
but new people thought alright they're a
part of this culture enough for me to
kind of check them out yeah he got real
weird in the early age he did yeah yeah
the [ __ ] sequence
I can count yeah what they'll all get
and the music was really like happy
sounding some of it was yeah I just
heard a song an Aussie song the other
day I can't believe he was this happy
shot in the dark it was like off that uh
uh it was the album where he had like
the the jelly coming out of his mouth
and he's holding up a Cressida that's a
live out in the speak of the devil that
was live sat he was contracted to do a
live record and they he didn't want to
do his music cuz Randy had just died and
he didn't want to put speak of the devil
on an album with Randy's name on it so
he just got Brad Gillis and those guys
they [ __ ] learned Sabbath songs in a
week what's the story behind Ozzie
Osborne's buzz cut I just saw a photo of
him with no was drunk and he [ __ ]
went bald he just did it and went bald
and then he was like Jack yeah speak of
the devil at the UH I forget where he
taped that but that was before speak of
the devil in that would be die of a
madman yeah that's the one I'm talking
about them that was taped at the same
time blizzard of aahhhs was that's why
Randy's on both of those records they
think they did them at the same time
okay those are those are not the ones
I'm thinking of those albums there man I
love talking about Ozzy you do I do
because there was a time we just sounded
really [ __ ] corny I don't know any
that well you know there was an ad there
was like an album or song I was just
like bark at the moon that was the one
that bothered me oh you know the park to
me that's 83 yeah did you like parka
Thurman I do this it's not my favorite
out no because it doesn't sound like him
was bark at the moon I got the song
alright bark at the moon it's not my it
was the first album like the first
studio album without Randy Rhoads so it
wasn't it's not as best da but this one
still I like the song bark at the moon I
like I like some songs all set it is
happy it is a happy feeling yeah did it
et know yeah so then that's when you
move towards hip hop so it but you'll
really listen to hip like new hip hop no
I checked out a long time when did you
check out I think I checked out
somewhere in the late 90s when I could
tell you 97 when they gave my universal
records gave Cash Money millionaires a
thirty million dollar deal maybe saying
huh
yeah and at that moment I went oh my god
they're paying black people to be dumb
like they're literally giving black
people money
that's showing them that if you're dumb
or dumber than this you can make a lot
of money and yeah [ __ ] work - yeah
yeah cuz they dumbed it down and he's
only gotten dumber it's gotten
ridiculously yeah and it bothers me
because I am someone phone to the black
community that I was like I called it at
that time ago
don't fall for this [ __ ] trick guys
right now there's still good minute left
New York I was out of it I was like okay
what's going on here there is still good
smart stuff but it's not dumb stuff has
got stuff really not that good either
what do you mean it's like it like
there's very rarely like there's a lot
of back pack stuff where they it's just
kind of like yeah see you're bumpy
knuckles has a new album on it's
phenomenal you know like like Kendrick
though I'm not a Kendrick Idol I don't
get it
I think he's only popular because
everything else is so [ __ ] right you see
him have that girl sing on stage and
[ __ ] them - that was [ __ ] fake
rebellion move [ __ ] move you wrote the
lyrics then go don't say that one shut
up yeah anyway Alabama right what
happened what do you think your audience
is gonna look like I don't write it just
don't [ __ ] write a man if somebody
says what you said don't you quote me I
could say that wow what a maverick yeah
yes that's right up there what same [ __ ]
Trump of the tawny spit out I'm wrong
I'm down with Bob Jim's relationship
with Robert De Niro sickens me because
it's truly affected everything
friendship right I love it wants to kiss
me on the cheek you might say no that's
funny I'm friends with Paul Herman hey
who's good friends with DeNiro they grew
up together and so I was at the at the
Emmys last year and I text Paul Herman
oh you text me was like hey I'm at the
Emmys and I go I hate De Niro's here it
goes oh yeah tell him and great grace
eyes wife yeah yeah yeah he goes tell
him and grace I said hello if not show
him this text anyway and I saw I didn't
think I was gonna get near him I'm
standing at the snack bar and there's
dinero and grace and his wife stand I go
excuse me miss grace and she was high
and I go up Paulie Herman sent this text
for me to show you
oh and then the near walks it was what
is this
it's from Paul Herman
reads it okay and he walks away okay
he walks away yeah he's a tough nut to
crack is it sometimes some people can
can't thing if you get in the right way
sure Jessa Kirsten I think the only to
the practive well thanks to Jessi that
she's kind of she was she helped that
relationship a lot Jessica he loves
Jessica Kherson she was vertically she's
great I had her open for me last year
she's hilarious
she's a really funny person yeah it's
very funny and really cool and and she'd
be much bigger than she I agree man you
know she's uh she's a very unique comic
and she's completely honest onstage
yes she's not full of [ __ ] no she
doesn't do things to do things right
no I really should right yes she killed
it in front of my crowd she did right
yeah she did she's aggressive she's loud
but it's not like that van all right not
a fake and it's not that fake confidence
it's just who she is
yeah yeah she hates her own guts which
is fun to watch yeah why I think we
don't hate yourself you can't be a comic
wait you sure yeah you know you're
probably not gonna be one I enjoy yeah I
mean I can't stand myself but you know I
might push the perception of confidence
up right as long as you be confident for
90 minutes onstage in front of a bunch a
[ __ ] they think I love myself and I'm
like no you've got it all wrong no just
so confident cocky no not [ __ ] I'm
garbage personified [ __ ] squared 3.14
[ __ ] are you are you single now no no oh
you're a relationship yes yes yes has
that been while you're on tour uh you
know it's uh it's it's I think it's
better because I'm away Oh meaning that
like you can miss each other and things
like that yeah you know what you bring
her no you don't wanna do that
how come too much [ __ ] on the road
listen she's cheating though I'm so
[ __ ] sick I know I'm not I always
hope you know you almost looking for I'm
looking at the front door at all time
have you ever had a girl cheat on you
yeah I have drunk yup it [ __ ] me what
happened to my early 20s in my late
teens so it
it [ __ ] me up to this day you know I
mean so tena [ __ ] you know would you
dump a girl now if she was doing it I
would use it as an excuse
Oh dump it it's good I mean it's the
same thing mark Normand said when he was
in here yeah don't you worry about your
girlfriend cheating on your knees like
now a part of me would be relieved yeah
to get out of it and then I could get
out of it and everything yeah you get
out of it unscathed I mean you you
become the victim right it's always
easier to get out when you're the victim
how long's been in your relationship for
four years we're engaged and you're
still going like well we're engaged but
if you cheat on me I can get out of it
you know I don't want her to cheat on me
but where you getting married you know
where no no dates you're engaged it's
been engaged for almost two years now
is she impatient or she like this is
cool by the way Russell hasn't started
in rapture Russell is a bunch of dates I
won't even mention any of your dates in
Ontario California Lincoln California
Saratoga Paula California Welch
Minnesota Montreal of course Just for
Laughs where Sam and I are also going to
be but the forest filled Stadium in
Queens yes that's the one I'm excited
about August 18th Forest Hills Stadium
and Kelsey here in New York you know and
you want to see a see Russell you can
see him there there's a big one to the
stadium on it's not gonna be small I was
trying to switch no because we did MSG
we did Barclays we did what's another
one that Louise shot a special in ah the
beacon the beacon have done the beacon
you know we've done almost done Radio
City yeah man he's running out of places
in New York and then I was like let's do
Nassau Coliseum I was like nah we asked
around they're like no you should do
Queens over the Carlos de Kooning that's
the way I have all these venues to do
you're like Meghan governor's Chapelle
was at the Gramercy last night I walked
by and saw his name on the marquee
that's a great little place like to work
that's like 300 seats yeah you know
that's a great could do anything
no I'm saying he's just working on me
and he can he can go do it on an hours
notice yeah yeah and I mean like I
literally like I'm gonna go do this
tonight and it'll be [ __ ] people lined
up around the block so that ten shows a
Radio City emits 50,000 yeah I did one
of them well you did yeah I did one of
them the night Chris Rock was on I was
it was pretty wild cuz I was just
hanging out I wasn't supposed to be on
the show when Dave was like eight you
want to do time and I'm like yeah
1015 min how that's awesome it was great
I mean I was so geeked you know to be
asked and you know it was rock first and
then our sinning hoes arsenio than Chris
Rock then intermission no then Jeff Ross
or then intermission than Jeff Ross than
me and then Dave oh my god what a lineup
yeah it was pretty well that's amazing
yeah I just saw Chris at the Comedy
Cellar and they invited me to do
something on his out he's doing sketches
on his album so I just went over and did
this we I was a very like two lines yeah
on his album sketch
yeah it was all yeah I texted you it was
really really it was like so last minute
I just see Matt the seller and the guys
was like you want to do something it's
around the corner we're doing it now and
I was like I'm gonna go home I'm tired
oh my chest go you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
almost didn't go but I'm saying to
myself I I'm so much like what are you
doing
ya know I didn't know what it was for
yeah that's a Chris Rock Album but still
you know exactly I don't have a
relationship with Chris that like the
first time I really spoke to him was
that that Dave show and I was drunk so
it doesn't count
he's one of the most one of the
brightest guys I've ever met like he's
like just about life stuff he has a
really if there's something going on and
you like want to bounce it off somebody
whether it's about the business or life
he always has a smart answer always like
a therapist you don't even know it he's
even know you're picking random friends
with all the other rocks yeah Tony
Jordan I just met candid you know Tony
Rock has a twin brother named Ken no no
what is he doing Tony lying to you man
Clifton he sounds and looks exactly like
Tony - that's I did not know Tony he
might have said that am I supposed to
have Tony rock in or really not here
when he's done building I was you all we
weren't here okay I love Tony yeah see
him in years
I'm Shirley this guy I took a picture I
was like really and he goes yeah I go
Tony's never mention cuz yeah you ever
watched Tony eat a burger I told Tony 15
years ago that's Tony's brother cam
yeah looks just like him yeah but he
nobody enjoys food more than Tony Rock
yeah but you gain any weight from it
watching him appreciate a burger I told
it was them it was one of them it was a
camera Vaart tony has the worst most
horrendous diet you'll ever see another
human have and he doesn't gain a pound
yeah she's still the same thin Wow was
you're appreciative about the burden I
don't know but he would just do
put the ketchup on and delicately treat
it like he really I always liked that
about him like this is a guy who
appreciates his food he like really he
doesn't take it for granted he loves
what he's eating it was just fun to
watch it like I appreciate it out of
necessity and I get [ __ ] mad at myself
after each meal I'll meet you
I ate pretzels in tortilla chips in
Tampa and I'm just pinching my stomach
before I walk on well you had the lamest
snacks I know I did like you're like oh
I can't I was so bad I had tortilla
chips all right sorry Jim he was so much
happier I really wasn't I was more
depressed fat than I really I would love
to I mean I just started losing weight I
don't know what the [ __ ] happening and
it's good sure whatever it caught me
that's the one people don't talk about
the upside of AIDS right lesions
whatever
yeah I'd feel if I were traveling all
the time like you are I would just want
snacks all the time I would want to know
one thing I've knocked out as snacks
yeah stop snacking all together how do
you get out of you can you can't manage
the diet though if you're going I mean
unless you just bring your food with you
um I know different countries just don't
eat don't I have trying to eat as much I
see despite how much I may like
something and I'm training jiu-jitsu
three four times a week now yeah where
you're training with John Jack Machado
in LA okay
do you like it I love it everyone loves
it I got it I just got my blue belt six
months ago yeah I watched it I trained
with hens oh I know you with Matt so I
trained the hens on one day and I
trained with Hickson one day oh man yeah
it was pretty wild to be with those good
hens always a weird God we should have
him in here he's one of those not
charismatic people I've ever met my like
oh yeah his energy like he's obviously a
[ __ ] you know he's never but he's
he's also uh uh he's he's an amazing
energy you can't not like hens Oh body
but like it's legit there's no [ __ ]
but I watched a video of him choking a
guy out on the floor what they do is
they grab you cross collar a cross
collar and he was so kept but he's
talking about and then you pull him into
your chest and he goes out and you watch
him and it's like that's what you can do
to a guy with his jacket on just grab
him and pull them in you strangled
really big on the cross caller and going
deep in the caller yeah Sara told me
that I think I want to be give a guy a
blue belt if you can't choke you out
like this he'll see it with me and Matt
Serra but on the train in the winter and
he'll see a guy in a winter car the car
that's a gift jacket so when I meant
parties or clubs or bars and I see you
know people knuckleheads and I'm looking
at what he's wearing on my card they
could take his sleeves I could take his
jacket I'm looking at everything on him
there it's so funny neck there's video
of hens all going after some bouncer
some guy was rude to him this story he
doesn't he doesn't have jujitsu [ __ ]
expert distance I would love it
Johanna Enzo always as a fight story I
know the [ __ ] maniac like God he told
us some story about who's in the paper -
how he beat up some disrespect - I see
he's very grateful do you know how much
I would love it Jim if you trained
jiu-jitsu and you did also didn't
respect you Jitsu distance so you
started starting you started starting
fights you know you didn't know that
you're not you were not skilled yet
beaten our players after two lessons and
we started doing karate kicks it happens
you know people want to test you I was
in the Philippines some guy like I was
sitting there I didn't even I was I got
into this lounge after the show it was
about twelve of us sitting around we had
this little section I'm literally
sitting there I haven't moved I haven't
walked in the club and I sat down I
didn't leave my seat at all sometimes
being a jerk and messing with somebody
with our table but I didn't see it
happening just walked by and so I
rubbing the guy's beard I'm like the
[ __ ] is that I didn't see it
then the guy walks around to me and he's
like hey are you Russell Peters and I'm
like yeah and he puts his hand out so I
shake his hand but I could see in his
face he's a dick yeah so he goes get the
[ __ ] out of here and I go no I'm not
leaving alright and and he goes what are
you doing here [ __ ] not like hey
[ __ ] like right what are you
doing your [ __ ] and then I got
really mad and I was like fine enough
I'm here [ __ ] your mother and I'm
holding his hand really tight now
because I'm looking at him cuz I'm
sitting down he's standing up and then
he goes oh you're uh you're a hard hand
shaker you're a firm handshake I go I do
Jiu Jitsu he goes so do i oh
let's see who has the best jujitsu feel
as soon as he said it I pulled his arm
straight through my legs up and put him
in an armbar did you yeah and then now
he tried to fall forward and I kicked
him right in his face
good for you yeah yeah in that moment
it's like all the hours and hours and
hours of training you were like this is
the greatest thing ever
I'm not [ __ ] even getting up yeah
that's a man attacked me
that's amazing wouldn't you like to
learn how to do that Jim I was and then
I literally sat back up after they
dragged him away I just sat back I'm
where's my drink gone mad I was more mad
that he spilt my drink all right I
wasn't mad about anything else the other
people dragged him away I didn't raise
my voice oh just like good night okay he
found out who had the better jujitsu and
that's a movie line that's exactly what
I'm self esteem at I go you do mine is
that good Wow
I had to respect my a teacher well I
want to take it though just because I
just go mad he's amazing he's in Long
Island
yeah hands always told me to come and I
was here in the city on 31st for 35th
Street I think when Matt took me down
there and introduced and everybody I've
interviewed a lot of those they're great
even Paul Giamatti is doing jujitsu on
billions yeah any trains at Enzo's
yeah I got a do it in the show when
that'd be cool if in real life Paul
Giamatti was just in your class everyone
says I would love it it's uh it's
addicting is it
like I'm jonesing I'm not training how
much do you train like three four days a
week four days a week and I'm
considering I might call henslowe
tomorrow and try and try and train with
them tomorrow what time do you go I
usually go my my pace there's no 1 p.m.
yeah do it man why not good I don't know
[ __ ] else you do I know I've no idea who
would dig it dude I'm very flexible go
through the roof you know your natural
jiu-jitsu artist what's this yeah give
daddy a cleansing so uh Queens is on
August 18th August 18 Forest Hill
Stadium
Forest Hill stadium we have to break
in a few minutes we will oh it's like
okay get it I just clip this reminding
people that they should go see Russell
Peters especially if you haven't seen
him before in this bush if you have
Russell is very funny I actually went to
the garden and saw you and today through
the show and I enjoyed it very much
I was impressed that you stayed yes I
think I saw you at Radio City
I would likely say I believe I did and I
believe that every time we've come as I
was obviously been a different regime
but each time what different person from
the regime comes to a different show
right
well yes who knows what'll happen to
August 18 yes who's gonna be there if I
have a girlfriend at that point maybe
I'll go out and watch you shoot in Abu
Dhabi do that'd be good you would love
that and I'm sure you can find a girl
boyfriend out there so I want someone to
travel it no not there you can't that's
illegal there's air trust me I want to I
don't want to travel with the you know I
stuff like that that's kind of why being
single stinks a little bit because it's
kind of fun too alright I think for me
traveling by myself was so much better
I've been doing it for so many years
though like I've always gone by myself
like I'm just I'm not in Tampa just
hanging out and I like you know like
idea the comedians were cool but you
just it's like ya doing [ __ ] doing
nothing
do people start were you I just
side-splitting heard this six shows
there for side-splitter isn't it's in
Tampa it's a clubs been in for 20 years
I read The Improv there once I didn't
like it
yeah it's I think it was big rule I
don't like to be room it was but it says
Lee I was like hi is like an opera house
is hey I didn't like it either for that
reason our people are still trying to
get you to do stuff from the first
special no no people not anymore they've
been found for it finally yeah yeah I'm
grateful that's over now
take it took a long time sometimes
people like yell out an old jokes doing
a look we'll be doing right like that's
Jack's been a decade I'm like what are
you that specials from 15 years ago I'm
like God Jesus special the one that
helped me get to where I am okay yeah
I was like one of the first ones to go
viral right yeah I was the first Youtube
guy yeah I kind of feel like all these
YouTube kids owe me something I think
you say entitled youi the
highest-earning comic last year was a
Kevin Hart what almost mean Kevin you're
on the list last year I wasn't on - were
last now you are on tour yeah but when
you
who are you are ya Russell quietly makes
that list every year it makes a lot of
money if you know more money than almost
any made it up to third at one point and
it never got mentioned ever like they're
all fawning over Jerry Seinfeld and
whoever else but yeah well we the
comedian's notice it every comic knows
Russell yeah every comic i watch the way
comics look at me that don't know me I I
do I do like the way they they all look
at me like he's not they give the look
of who the [ __ ] are you and I'm like
well I thirty years in the game [ __ ]
Yeah right you can respect my host and
they literally don't know that he makes
more money on a tour than I've made in
their entire careers I'm very well aware
of that
thank you Jim you can see Russ just tell
everybody else I'd be great